MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So we continue our discussion
on the Feynman Calculus,
and continue now talking
about Fermi's Golden Rule.
The heart of calculating
decay rates and cross sections
is Fermi's Golden Rule.
And it simply tells
you how we can
use the calculation
of amplitudes
and the available phase space to
make assessment of decay rates
and cross sections.
So the amplitude M holds all
the dynamical information.
And we can see that we can
calculate the amplitude
by evaluating Feynman diagrams
directly using Feynman rules.
The available phase space
holds is a kinematic factor,
and it depends on
masses and the energies
and the momentum of
the particles involved.
And then again, Fermi's
Golden Rule simply
says that the transition rate or
decay rates and cross sections
are given by the product
of the phase space
and the square of the amplitude.
How does this now look like?
If you look at the
Golden Rule for Decays,
here we suppose
having one particle
decaying into a second,
third, fourth, n-th particle.
This is that the
decay rate is given
by matrix element, the amplitude
squared, and a term which
is C, the phase space factor.
There's also a
factor here in front.
This S has to count-- we have
to account for the fact that we
might have the same
particle in the final state,
or the same particle
occurring multiple times.
And we have to make sure that
we don't have double counting.
In this double counting
has to be correct.
If all particles are different,
this extra factor is 1.
We'll look at this
some more later.
Now, at first glance, this
looks like rather complicated.
But if you try to
assess now what
those individual
terms mean, you will
see that it's very accessible.
So when we try to calculate
a use from this golden rule
for the case, we to integrate
over all outgoing particle
four-momenta.
But we have three
kinematical constraints.
The first one is that
the outgoing particles
have to be on mass.
So they have to
be on mass shell.
We talked about this issue of
virtual particle [? inertia ?]
before.
But simply, they have to--
the energy of the particle
has to follow this condition.
This is a delta
function, which simply
means that this gives
us, if the argument is
0, the delta
function, which was 1.
The argument is non-zero.
The function returns 0.
So this [INAUDIBLE]
simplifies this term here.
So this first part here in
our Fermi's Golden Rule simply
accounts for the fact
that outgoing particles
have to be on mass shell.
Outgoing particles also have
to have positive energies.
And this explains our second
factor here, this factor.
And so this factor is
the heavy side function,
and this is simply 0
for negative values
and 1 for positive values.
And the last one means
that energy and momentum
of the particle
have to conserve.
So the first particle
minus the second,
third, and so on for each
of the component for energy
and for those [? three ?]
components of the momenta
have to be 0 for
this to return 1.
So again, another
delta function.
That's also factors of pi.
And the simple rule here
is for each delta function,
you have to account for a
vector of 2 pi in your function.
So this basically
explains already
everything we see
here on this slide.
So now we can calculate.
And I recommend to have a
look at Griffiths chapter
6 for this.
If you look at two
particle decays.
So one particle
into two particles.
This simplifies
quite tremendously
because of all the
delta functions here
and the heavy side functions.
This equation simplifies
directly to a factor.
You have the momentum
of the particle
here, and a matrix element.
Again you have this
statistical factor here
to account for the fact that
there might be duplicates
and you want to keep track
of the statistical factor.
For scattering, the equation
looks almost the same.
So you have the same
phase space factor.
Almost the same
Matrix element.
Again, this is
the transition way
it is given by, as Fermi's
Golden Rule tells us,
by the matrix elements squared.
And the phase space factor.
This overall effect,
as we look at later,
they are slightly different.
But here, as a rule,
we want to make sure
that we have a way to
assess cross section.
Did this make sense?
We'll see later in more detail.
For two body decays in
the center of mass frame.
You know that the
initial momenta
in the center of mass frames
of particle 1 and particle 2
have to be the same.
The outgoing momenta
also have to be the same.
They don't necessarily have to
be the same as the [INAUDIBLE]
But if any uses of the
differential cross-section
can be calculated quite
straightforwardly.
Again, there's a
matrix element squared.
You have the final state
momenta, the initial state
momenta.
And divide this by the sum of
the energies squared together
with an extra factor here.
So what we have seen here is
just we have looked at it.
I didn't explain
how we got to this.
But we have seen
from this Golden
Rule, which helps us to assess.
And we have seen how we can
calculate the phase space
factor.
The next lecture, we now
see how we can calculate
the matrix element itself.
And we'll start doing this by
using a toy experiment or toy
model, such that the discussion
simplifies, algebra simplifies
quite a bit.